all right well give you a choice you can
either have mario hezonia or this horse
will take the horse when people ask you
what happened here
tell them King James still rules the
east also tell them I'm better than
Michael Jordan
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
someone's coming
wait what a free-agent come into house
Hornets we have to blow the Charlotte
horn we have to blow the show at all
wait there's no rider just the horse how
did you is there any defense in this
realm anymore you said what it's meat
pie
[Music]
hey guys we wait LeBron
what's your half actually thank you hey
guys guys hey guys hey everyone so glad
you all could be here I just figured
since so many of you summer in Los
Angeles anyway it would be fun to invite
everyone over to my new brentwood castle
for some mingling some pampering a
little tampering but before we dig into
our delicious fastfire dort is no place
meat pies I do have some big news Ben
Simmons hit a three-pointer I did I did
oh speaking of which my servant I mean
my lord commanders have informed me that
the pies are ready so everybody say it
with me it's time for me so you think
invented meat pie Monday's you should
call it maize meat pies because he's so
corn
Oh on Kyrie I must ask you what are
those oh yes these are the new Kyrie 5
boots in honor of sir sponge Robert
square tunic oh so creative you're such
an artist
hey how's grumpy boys so you're on
Brooklyn now eh
indeed we are oh I love it such a good
fit great young call for you to
demoralize Oh Alex Caruso's here
excuse me gentlemen oh hey Carmelo uh uh
sir new with you oh you know got a lot
of irons in the fire
oh yes uh house is showing interest no I
mean I'm actually a blacksmith now oh
well you know I for one think you've
been treated so unfairly by all those
blog boy media folk analytics people a
night of your caliber you sir should be
on a house it's ridiculous oh thank you
well you know if you need anyone I'm I
mean yeah problem with the house nets is
that with the Cap'n all's yeah but have
you talked to Dame
I think house blazes might be desperate
might be interested in the night of your
caliber okay
Oh sir Jason and sir Jalen how are
things
well you know it's never easy when you
lose your best night no it's tough to
see al horford on how sixes hey celtic
guys um so I was wondering if it is
possible for me to borrow these Sol
bucks you see for I have a new teammate
he is a bit um sorry James Gordon
Hayward smashed it it's a long story
oh wow okay what even happens when you
smash a soul box
hey LeBron just want to say thank you so
much for having us Paul and I had a bla
you guys leaving no we're just about to
start a big 1k tournament oh I'd love to
but actually played a game yesterday and
you know I'm trying to manage me load
fine understood well so glad you guys
could come and so excited for this
little crosstown rivalry remember guys
the only beef here is in the pies all
right
[Music]
your generation is soft of your load
management of your analytics UAA you
shoot the houses the gods of this game
not stand for this a reckoning is coming
caribou is like weirdly over-sexualized
or whatever brawny Jude and who's
getting along what's going on with Gian
over there okay yeah I think he might in
my special pie oh damn it junior I just
don't understand why would I leave this
place it's good Fred
what do you mean it's good Kawai showed
us the way showed us what it takes now
it's our North me you oh gee the rest we
show the realm we're more than just a
cloth what
[Music]
Kawai excite you
hello I think it's a Fanning you want us
to sign your ball
Oh